[Music]
whether he is the most famous artist on
the planet you know that I'm sure people
would you know dispute that and would
name other names but he I mean he is a
global superstar it was just such a
brilliant painter he broke rules that
hadn't been broken for centuries you
know and he he did it his way he kind of
is a bit like the tortured rock stars
Kurt Cobain or Jimi Hendrix and and he
has that sort of rock star up here
we appreciate him for his struggle for
his energy for his emotion for his
belief he believed in himself
[Music]
everybody has a different story about
what happened to him he was a nice quiet
man always skulking about then he comes
here with a girl who I reckon was out of
his league and the next thing I hear
he's killed himself
this film is history in the making the
world's first ever fully painted feature
film exploring the tortured life and
mysterious death of one of the world's
greatest ever artists Vincent van Gogh
he was mad he was an interesting man he
was a genius
starring Chris O'Dowd Saoirse Ronan and
Douglas booth it quite literally brings
to life some of his most inspirational
works rather than using computers to
digitally animated all 64 and a half
thousand frames have been laborious li
painted the vision of an oscar-winning
director and his wife I've done a lot of
computer animation if I thought I could
get the same look of oil painting moving
before your eyes in the computer I would
have probably done it in the computer
because this I wouldn't have gone to all
the trouble of finding 124 painters in
three different countries setting up you
know three studios to achieve this and
do it so painstakingly by Handel that
they actually move each brushstroke
frame by frame unless I thought it could
come up with a look which you couldn't
achieve any other way despite their
relatively small budget the filmmakers
managed to get a stellar cast on board
who bought into the project and perhaps
it's no surprise when this is the
closest they'll ever get to having their
portrait painted by Van Gogh I've never
worked on anything quite like this and I
probably won't ever again because it's
not like an animation where you just
turn up and you do your voice and you go
away it's a performance that you put in
and you then there's there's two artists
that the actor and then there's the
painter and you both work to bring it to
life although I'd say they've put in a
lot more work than I do
I did what did that nobody ever do for
us you see each brush stroke you see it
and it has a texture to it I believe
under other animations however great
don't have because it's been done by
hand we paint sixty two thousand four
hundred and fifty paintings and to do
that we need a lot of pain
and behind each of these black curtains
we have a painter the film is five years
in the making involving more than a
hundred unbelievably talented and
dedicated artists from all over the
world so this is the Asian who's done
more shots on the film than anyone else
for seconds yeah it's 98 frames so he
does a quarter or a third of a second
each day so he's in my twenty days just
for that one shot of the car going
through with the women
most days I do about six to seven frames
what you have to do is get the movement
believable and the other thing that
happens and I'm really bad at this is
that I'll move the face and I'll forget
to move say the hairline so if face
looks like she's shifting and her hair
stays the same so you have to
concentrate the whole time is quite the
antithesis of the high-tech studio you
might expect for a feature animation
there are three Studios the lead here in
Poland where they're using an
unprecedented process to take each frame
filmed using actors and paint over every
single one of them basically those four
stages the earliest stage which is
shooting it against blue-screen with
actors and then putting a reference over
that this is for the painters to make it
easy for them to paint and this bit was
the final result your Postal Service
can't find him what makes you think I
can just use your additional son an
important man like mr. t or van Gogh ask
around what do I say when I find him
it's amazing what the paint picks up and
what these what these artists have
managed to do just even the tiny micro
expressions it was also fun to go and
and meet a bunch of painters that for
two years have just been painting your
face
[Music]
glad to see you're honoring God not like
your friend mad barbers friend we cover
around 130 original Vincent van Gogh
paintings in the film and bring those to
life and 60 minutes of the film is in
Vincent Technicolor and the flashbacks
are in and this very nice black and
white style visually loving Vincent will
undoubtedly blow audiences away but at
the heart of any great movie are the
characters and the plot and bang Goff's
madness his genius not to mention the
mystery surrounding his death were a
gift for the script writers working on
this film Vincent died on the 29th of
July 1890 from gunshot wounds to the
chest and more than 125 years on there's
still speculation over whether it was
suicide or even murder
it's these conflicting accounts of his
last days that caught the imagination of
the filmmakers of loving Vincent why he
would kill himself when he was just
succeeding for the first time in eight
years so for eight years he'd been
struggling he had had many knockbacks
and then in the year of his death he had
brilliant reviews and also money
declared him the most exciting new
artist and he seemed to be cured he
wasn't drinking as much anymore and yet
six weeks later his dead I think it's
the tragedy you know in the sorrow
because we can all relate to that
you know why do we love soap operas so
much because we see something within us
of the poor person that that's in the
script but interestingly enough some
people don't think that van Gogh was the
greatest painter they think it was a
brilliant painter but perhaps not the
greatest but it's the story it's
all-encompassing did he cut off his
earlobe and give it to a prostitute as a
gift
you know there's so many different myths
and stories
van Gogh was born here in the
Netherlands in 1853 and its capital
Amsterdam has become the focal point for
fans to pay homage to perhaps the
country's greatest export he didn't
become an artist until his late twenties
and in the following ten years produced
nearly 900 paintings
most in the last two years before he
died and the me thing he only actually
sold one during his lifetime the van
Gogh Museum is visited by nearly 2
million people every year and holds the
largest and most important collection of
his paintings in the world
200 of his oil paintings are on show
here the bulk from the last few years of
his life in France which were not only
his most productive but also his most
troubled this vast collection gives a
fascinating insight into the
extraordinary personality behind the
arts as well as some of his techniques
Vincent painted over 30 self-portraits I
believe and what does that say about him
as a man I mean what kind of a character
wall say Vincent himself he had a very
stubborn personality but that
stubbornness on the one hand didn't
really endear him necessarily to people
around him but on the other hand it also
meant that he was a very stubborn artist
you know he pursued his calling if you
like you know also in a very stubborn
way in a very disciplined way but that
made after all that he in a very short
period of 10 years you know created this
enormous amount of work and created this
enormous legacy the museum also holds
400 drawings and 700 letters many
written to his beloved little brother
Theo who was Vincent's biggest supporter
both emotionally and financially and
give a unique understanding into the
mind of a genius his trials and
tribulations he shares in his letters
with his brother with with friends but
mostly with his brother and he really
does talk about the challenges that he
experiences both as an artist but also
in his daily life and the loneliness
that he experienced and experiences and
the fact that he is feels misunderstood
also later on in his career his
frustration that he is not breaking
through as an artist that people don't
understand his work that they that he
doesn't sell of course you know that is
sort of a burden for him it was the last
letter Vincent wrote to his brother a
week before his death that inspired the
film he wrote
cannot speak other than by our paintings
and this is exactly what the filmmakers
wanted to do to tell the story of Van
Gogh through his own work
letting the paintings tell his story
loving Vincent is a groundbreaking film
fully painted by a team of more than a
hundred artists over a period of five
years it tells the story of Vincent van
Gogh through his own paintings
it's a painted animation which means we
shoot it like a normal movie
they then project every frame of the
movie onto a canvas and then artists
paint over over each frame in the style
of Van Gogh
in his lifetime he was so unappreciated
people didn't you know he wasn't
celebrated he was he felt like he wasn't
very good but he was desperate to be an
artist and he just worked and worked at
it and I think to all artists that
appeals people that are afraid to go
into an art gallery because they feel
intimidated that want to find out more
about the man himself or really love
this film because it's almost like
sitting talking to him you know you hear
him come alive through his paintings the
paintings have sounds they have words
it's not watching poetry about him
[Music]
filmmakers came here to the van Gogh
Museum in Amsterdam to gain an insight
into this great painters work his life
and his techniques van Gogh tragic life
his struggle with depression the fact
that he cut off his own ear and
committed suicide are as famous as these
self-portraits but this film asked the
question did he actually shoot himself
or was it in fact murder and attempts to
reflect the man behind the madness
the thing that really amazed me about
Vinson was that he had actually failed
for careers and was the black sheep of
the family and completely depressed and
alone when he was 27 years old and he
turned himself from someone who everyone
had written off as a nobody a nonentity
an unpleasant person into them probably
the the most famous artist in history
this is the famous house that Vincent
rented in all in the late 1880s on which
he described in detail to his brother
Theo in his letters and this is perhaps
one of his most famous paintings his
bedroom and these paintings along with
his letters give an incredible insight
into Vincent van Gogh slice and also his
state of mind
so the backdrop to these masterpieces is
an enthralling and tragic story of a
loner plagued by mental illness who
never got to enjoy his own success the
beginning of the end for Vincent came
when he cut off his ear the point at
which his illness began to take over he
was sort of losing his facilities that
he was not in control of himself anymore
it may have led to hallucinations
we know from descriptions at the time
that he also then had to be restrained
because he started to eat paint
he felt he needed to commit himself to
an institution to the asylum in Santa me
where he actually is voluntarily
submitted himself because he felt he was
no longer in control
one theory that's been discredited is
the idea that Van Gough SMAT nurse
fueled his artistic genius on the
contrary Vincent made his best work when
lucid there is this perceived notion
that he was just mad and he was just
crazy and that you know he was just
crazy Lee flinging paint at the canvas
and was sort of out of control and that
is something that is patently not true I
think we need to divorce the art that he
made the paintings that he created from
his illness because he made them almost
despite of his illness rather than
because of it
[Music]
here we have all of our paintings drying
so this is from the fight put them in
the rain this one here this is actually
based upon the original painting our
mongrel on to somehow reflect van Gogh
genius the filmmakers needed
exceptionally talented artists we would
not only be able to replicate his work
but we'll also be able to animate it it
was very hard to convince them to paint
in different style they have to paint a
couple of shots to get this and then we
just like machines you know they pay
like Bangkok I think the the biggest
problem is that you have to scratch it
off and then you just like you paint
amazing painting and you are so happy
about this it looks like van Gogh
painting and then you just have to
scratch it we have to be very patient so
when you are an artist you think that
you are the best and that your work is
super great and then somebody told you
that now you have to change it and all
you have to scratch it or you have to
delete frames and then you have to
struggle with yourself and your ego
actually so that is that's the dress the
white bit of the dress and then that's
the dress shadow we worked really hard
we worked long long hours we do sort of
9 10 hour days and sometimes the
animation doesn't work as well as it
should and you'll be told to delete it
and start again so that's sort of having
your work up up for such intense
criticism is it's quite sort of it's not
belittling or or anything that's
humbling
that's what reminds me of Van Gogh
really we're sort of in
his footsteps
[Music]
I became faster I was always a slow
painter but now because you have to
paint fast so you learn how to be kind
of really concentrated and then just
paint we need to be really patient
because of course we're not we're not
machines
many have uprooted their lives to base
themselves here in Poland for months if
not years
utterly dedicated to learning Vincent's
style I've robbed the forum eight months
eight and that's it now no more you're
going home yes I want to go home to my
children through as best thing that's
ever happened to me
sometimes I hate it sometimes I love it
it's like a roller coaster yeah it's
been fun all the way and exciting
[Music]
when an unofficial trailer was leaked on
Facebook the response was staggering
attracting over a hundred million views
within weeks
[Music]
it just went mad and I just I saw it
popping up on my Facebook feed it was
all my friends they didn't even know it
was anything have you seen this this is
amazing if I actually a minute I haven't
actually had a so much interest in a
movie I've made from my peers and people
my age ever that everyone thinks it's
the coolest thing ever there are a few
films where the filmmaking process is as
fascinating as the film itself but that
is certainly the case here opening shot
of the film we descend from starry night
down over I'll pass the yellow house and
into the the famous night cafe and
that's shot is 1,250 frames which meant
we had to do 625 paintings and because
it was a moving shot they pretty much
had to do a new painting each time so we
had three painters working on that shot
for over six months we have definitely
without a doubt invented the slowest
form of filmmaking ever devised in 120
years starry starry night
paint your palette blue and gray I
imagined you would love to know that all
these years later a hundred artists who
really are completely inspired by him by
putting this work into his story shadows
on the heels
sketch the trees and the daffodils I
just hope that he's watching from his
art studio on the cloud and thinking
yeah we actually appreciate him now he
saw beauty and everything bit sunrise or
a sunset or some flower his art his life
his life story the drama the perceived
drama of his life and the myth that has
arisen you know that makes for justice
you know global icon that he is nowadays
I love that you can see if you humans
they heat the human touch to it it's not
it's not perfect because the
brushstrokes are changing the whole time
so it feels alive and the paint is alive
and when you had it on that on that
scale and the cinema screens can I hoped
me quite quite magical
[Music]
for they could not love you in a world
where everything seems to be going
digital and so many decisions are driven
by saving time and money the choice to
spend years painstakingly painting tens
of thousands of canvases seems about
more than just authenticity this is a
labor of love and proof there are some
things modern technology just can't
capture you took your life as lovers
often do but I could have told you
Vincent
this world was never meant before one is
beautiful